Tom Verducci Sports Illustrated senior
baseball writer joins us on the show Tom
a couple things to talk about Giancarlo
Stanton has been unbelievable certainly
in the second half of the season explain
how often you have a marquise guy clear
waivers and do you think that means
Stanton could end up with another team
this year yeah it's usually because he's
making so much money but it happens a
lot guys do clear waivers that doesn't
mean that the Marlins are going they
literally give him away
I don't see a trade happening ban
because of the contract because the fact
that the team being sold
he's a definition of a franchise player
right yeah he's young really good he's
popular I wouldn't want to be Derek
Jeter or walk in there the first thing I
do is trade my best player so that's not
happening yeah tom is calling the
Yankees Red Sox from Fenway on MLB
Network Friday at 7:00 Eastern with Bob
Costas also his book the Cubs way now
available in stores everywhere wanted to
give you the proper introduction the
Dodgers 50 games over 500 we've seen
this before teams are built for the
regular season not necessarily the
postseason what is different about this
Dodgers team do you think this year as
opposed to previous years well it's the
deepest team in baseball and I thought
there was one flaw in the team and that
was not enough depth of starting
pitching because remember last year the
postseason when they lost you know Kenta
Maeda
Julio Reyes they were out of games
really early so it didn't matter that
they had this monster bullpen with six
seven options and I think the trade for
you Darvish really covered the last hole
because now you've got locked down
starting pitchers well at least they're
not going to lose a game in the first
four innings of the game and I think we
look at a scenario again neither the
Cubs or the Nationals now I think after
the first one assuming Kershaw comes
back and you know he's just as good they
match up well against those teams I
would not have said that before so hey
listen to me
it's the Dodgers in the field right now
they're that good now that could wind up
being the o1 Mariners but if you look at
those old one Mariners day they're
starting pitching and even their bullpen
but especially they're starting pitching
was mediocre knew and
you have to have good starting pitching
and we all talk about bullpens but look
at the Cubs last year and the Indians
ran out of starting pitching in the
World Series you still need three good
starting pitchers but if you look at
this Dodger team there's always going to
be a team that you don't match up well
against and that's why I caution Dodger
fans last week when I said I know it
feels like it's your team you're all in
on you know it's your year Hugh Darvish
coming over everybody's playing well
it's just that you run into a hot
pitcher you run into a team that just
has your number there is there a team
that you see that you know could provide
that scenario well you know let's say
Strasburg comes back he's fully healthy
Gio Gonzalez is at a really good year
you know Scherzer Strasburg Gio you know
that may be good enough to take out the
Dodgers as deep as they are because
those are three guys you can take the
ball to the eighth-inning they're that
good I think that's probably what it
will take I do like what the Cubs have
done in terms of go down in cantana
and fortifying their bullpen with Justin
Wilson I do still think you need to let
these against the Dodgers even though
they've hit some way better this year
than last year
I just don't think Cubs are good enough
to stake out the Dodgers I think they're
just not having the same season there's
too many holes in the lineup offensively
Dodgers are better deeper Cain the Cubs
Mike Trout possibility for MVP they're
in the playoff chase for a wild-card
berth but he won the MVP last year and
they weren't in the hunt at all the
possibility that Trout could be you know
how to vey judge whoever else you're
going to throw in there but that
possibility is what right now in your
opinion it's real and I would not have
said that maybe a month or two ago I
just thought there was too much time
they'd missed but the fact is now the
angels are in this race you know a lot
of these MVP awards you know Dan or won
in September right big names big moments
get your team in that will count for
more he can finish the year with 117
games played and that doesn't sound like
a lot but that's as many as George Brett
when he won the MVP in 1980
now George planted what 390 or whatever
it that was amazing we focused on
batting average back then but trout if
you
wind up with amazing numbers is on-base
percentage is about 470 so yeah I
thought it would have been impossible
I'm not saying it I think out today is
the guy to beat you but anything don't
count out Mike Trout why is it that
we're trying this revisionist history if
Stanton would hit somehow hit 62 home
runs that now we're looking at would
that be the new home run mark and I want
you sorry and you know we we Marty we
closed the book on the steroid era here
well maybe but why are why is this a
conversation that all of a sudden
Stanton has a chance to you know surpass
Roger Maris here's the single-season
home run chance yeah that's the shape of
the steroid era man it's just that
there's not enough legitimacy to those
records now that being said those are
records they're not going to change
right the homerun record is 73 you get a
whole list with bonds McGwire Sosa that
no one's changing that but in the minds
of fans it will always be there so if
you want to say that you buy into
authenticity more for Stanton than you
do bond you can do that an individual
fan he's not going to get the record if
he had 62 home runs but there's a lot of
people are going to say you know I have
more appreciation for what Stanton did
and from what bonds it and I would be
one of them if I said you could have
their future judge or Stanton you take
it I would take Stanton um there's not
much of a difference in age actually was
not love era judge I think he's going
through a lot of young players too it's
his first full year in the big league
man he's still making adjustments he
will but right now you talk about making
adjustment Benton is a little bit like
Mark McGwire when Mark first came up he
had no clue how he hit 47 home runs or
49 home runs back as a rookie but he
really learned how to hit later in his
career and I think that's you're seeing
now for Stanton he's not just a big
strong guy with home runs by mistake
he's studying pitchers now he's learning
them he's got a game plan Jessamine he's
made with his closed stance which is so
impressive you're just seeing him now I
just think hitting his prime years thank
you sir appreciate your time tom have
fun with
on Friday night next time the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience